الان نستعرض خارطه التطورات الميدانيه
الاخرى في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في
الساعات الماضيه والبدايه طبعا من شبه
جزيره القرم تصدرت المشهد هذه المنطقه
اليوم باعلان السلطات في مدينه سباق عاصمه
شبه الجزيره احباطه هجوم الاوكرانيين
بالمسيرات تسبب في تعطيل حركه العبارات
والسفن في البحر الاسود لفتره محدوده
ثم عادت الى طبيعتها اما في خير صن في
الجنوب
فتقول الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه قصفت احياء سكنيه في عاصمه
المقاطعه ما ادى الى مقتل مدني بينما
افادت سلطاته خيرسن الموالي لروسيا بصد
محاولتين اوكرانيتين لعبور نهر دينيبر الى
الضفه اليسرى الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه
اما في زابولوجيا فشهرت قصفا مكثفا للقوات
الروسيه على اكثر من 50 هدفا في 13 منطقه
سكنيه بحسب الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
في زابروجيا
عفوا وشاهدت مقاطعه ايضا
قصفا روسيا باربعه صواريخ من طراز اس 300
اطلقتها القوات الروسيه من اقليم بيل جرود
الروسي وفق لاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
خاركير